you share your everyday interactions you
find humor in things that happen to you
just when you're walking around I always
enjoy that any good ones lately I do
thank you sir uh I was at Macy's
department store you familiar yes shoe
shop sure I do I go out like other
people yeah
what are you doing look I have a butler
that carries me from store to store
talking about a wheelbarrow no I go to
forever 21 my jeans attaboy I'm a
regular guy you are sure your little
giraffe head popping over the car right
remember who show you're on here pal we
got some exotic beasts so you're at
Macy's I know nice I met Macy's this by
the way you wanna throw five hundred
percent true this one is not I this is
about 97% true I'm puppets of up for
humor now listen I'm at the Macy's I'm
in the men's department and listen yeah
and I'm and I found some pants that fit
me I got a 29 by 28 body that's not a
leg for a man right you know it's like
the pants for a GI Joe
they're happy you got your clubs
yeah even after all these years it felt
pretty good to get just a little more
anyway so you get that you got some good
pants you'll get over it come on pal
check it out so I have I found some
pants I'm walking to the dressing room
and there's a guy that's wandering
around who I'll say it dicey looks dicey
Yeah right and he's and he's got a Tommy
Bahama shirt on he's got a stack of nine
more Tommy Bahama shirts and it's one of
Jimmy Buffett cruise I don't know if
this guy's doing then I like him I also
don't like this he's got a lollipop
right so he's sucking on this lollipop
in a way that I've never enjoyed a
lollipop in my entire life
he's sucking on this thing these things
like he's working it too hard he's
working hard it's clanking against his
teeth you know he's got this lollipop
yeah so I'm walking into the dressing
room and he's going to the counter to
check out with his nine shirts and he's
again he's got this lollipop he's
working this thing hard and the woman
behind the counter says boy you're sure
enjoying that lollypop and he and he
goes yeah it's banana would you like to
taste my banana George I of course stop
the parents can wait right I gotta see
what's about to go down here yeah yeah
she says what and he goes nothing drops
the shirts at runs like how I want your
theory right there I do have a theory
think I'm asking
he either either this works and he ends
up banging her in their dressing room or
I witnessed this woman throw at the
lollipop killer that's my guy
you